à côté de la maison familiale
soljenitsyne s'est fait construire
spécialement pour son travail une maison
de deux étages en briques et en bois ici
une grande salle bibliothèque où il a
réuni son énorme documentation au dessus
le bureau où il écrit et dans lequel
sera enregistré l'entretien
nathalie est plus que l'épousé avec sans
se gêner zine son unique collaboratrice
elle note classe d'après pont conseil
chez les sujets ni jean pas de
secrétaire pas même une employée de
maison
non seulement nathalie s'occupe de
l'éducation de ses enfants
mais c'est encore el aidé de sa mère qui
fait le ménage et la cuisine
quant aux méthodes de travail de
l'écrivain elles sont méticuleuse et
rigoureuse excusez-moi alexandre ce
jezzine mais je suis stupéfait par
toutes ces fiches qui couvre toutes vos
tables à quoi sert-elle matériaux
pétrole et gaz et techniques tandis qu
on partage on cherche tous les niveaux
du vélo il faut qu'on monte à jour quand
on collectionne le pâton community mais
qu'attend le mien au genou et papiers
afin de masquer woippy a généré au nom
malinké tout ce qui y est dit mme aline
quelque chose qu'il faudra d'autres
suggestions si ce mini à face estime
escato la mangouste rahman et bernad 11
buts sur ce total est en âge au rugby
familles occupent ou chose que votre
profession a pas ton faye dit nick
qu'ils rasent les murs jusqu'au bout du
système
et c'est qu'elle